هذا وخرج الاف الى الشوارع في تل ابيب
لدعم اسر الاسرى المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
خلال مسيرتهم الاحتجاجيه الاسبوعيه وكان
من بين المتحدثين شارون الوني كونيو
المفرج عنها مع ابنتيها التوام وانتقدت
شارون موقف حكومه رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
وقالت انها نقضت عهدها ولم تقدم اي تقدم
اي مبادره اخيره لارجاع الاسرى
احيا
يجب على الدوله ان تفعل كل ما في وسعها
لاعاده الاشخاص الذين اهملوا في منازلهم
في الاسابيع الاخيره لم تقدم الحكومه اي
مبادره خاصه بها وكل يوم تقريبا تاتي
اخبار من غزه فقط عن الجثث اقول لمجلس
الوزراء لقد عانت ايما ويولي بما فيه
الكفايه لقد نقضت العهد معهم مع زوج ديفيد
واريل وصهري والرهائن الاخرين اطالب بان
يكون هدفكم ال هو ارجاع الهاء
احياء